Daniel: Hello and welcome, everyone, to
the active inference institute.
This is session one of the course physics
as Information Processing with Chris
Fields.
First we'll have Andrea Guere and Chris
Introduce themselves.
And then we'll carry on with the first
lecture.
Here.
Check out the video description for a
link to the course course overview
website where you can ask questions that
will be answered asynchronously register
to participate in the discussions, which
happen about two weeks after each of the
six lecture sessions and just learn more
about this area.
So thank you both so much for joining
into this adventure.
We are starting now.
And first, please Aguirre Giray,
introduce yourself.
And then Chris introduction and lecture.
Thank you.
Ander: Hello.
So I'll be the course assistant.
I'm a postdoc in math, specializing in
improbability, and I have a deep interest
in the physics of information.
And I've been familiar with Chris's
papers for a while.
So, yeah, just here to learn myself.
Chris: Thank you, Andrew.
And thank you, Daniel.
I'm Chris Fields and I'll be presenting
this course in six sessions and Aguirre
will be organizing discussion sessions
after each of those.
And all of this is explained on the
course website.
So let's start.
This is a course on physics as
information processing, and this first
session will be historical perspective on
the idea that physics is or is about
information processing.
And I'll just start with a few quotations
that span the middle of the 20th century
from Wittgenstein in 1920s saying the
world is all that is the case.
So defining the world in terms of facts,
not objects.
Landauer in the early 60s proclaiming
that information is physical.
And then John Archibald Wheeler, who in
many ways is the grandfather of this era,
recently stating it is it from Bit.
So things come from information, I E
bitstrings.
And if nothing else, this shows that
formulations of this idea get pithier as
the 20th century rolls on.
But the history goes back farther clearly
than the 20th century.
But I'm only going to really talk about a
piece of it and the timeline that I'll
actually discuss today.
The most relevant history of this idea
goes back to the mid 19th century.
And the first specific thing I'll talk
about is Clausia's definition of entropy.
.
But with the beginning of the
understanding of thermodynamics and the
role of information in thermodynamics,
you get this very interesting
multidisciplinary progression of ideas
that incorporates the beginning of
quantum theory.
And the beginning of quantum theory can
kind of be dated to the first Solve
conference in 1928 and the famous debate
between Bohr and Einstein over whether
quantum theory is about knowledge,
information or objects things.
But it incorporates a lot of work in
computer science and logic and
mathematics.
So, interestingly, computer science was
Born effectively in the mid 30s with the
work of Church and Turing, which very
rapidly converged with the work in
physics.
So today we'll be talking about both
computer science and physics.
And then in the second half of the 20th
century, this just exploded into a huge
area.
And in consequence of that mid 20th
century development, we're beginning to
see a new idea about physics which is
roughly encapsulated in quantum
information theory.
And the new idea is this.
It's that what physics is actually about
is information transfer across boundaries
and the information we can represent.
The information transfer like this.
And this is a convention I'll use.
A boundary is always a blue ellipse.
And the agents that are exchanging
information across this boundary are
conventionally called Alice and Bob,
which is just a more polite way of saying
A and B.
And when you think about this picture, it
becomes clear that what physics is really
about is communication.
And this is a wild redescription of the
idea of what physics is compared to the
ideas of Newton or LaPlace or even the
19th century ideas.
And it's very different from the idea
that's been preserved in 20th century
physics in the lineage of Einstein and
others who viewed classical physics as,
in a sense, either as completely
fundamental or as a fundamental adjunct
to quantum theory.
So this way of thinking about physics is
a very deeply quantum theoretic way of
thinking about physics.
And where we're going in this course
today is really how did this all happen?
It's the origin story.
And then in the next session, I want to
discuss quantum information theory
explicitly and in particular, how quantum
theory makes this conclusion that physics
is about communication very simple and
obvious, much more obvious than it is in
classical physics where it takes work to
formulate this idea.
Then in the next session, we're going to
talk about semantics and how observations
become meaningful to the agents who make
them and hence how actions become
meaningful to the agents who make them.
Then in August, we'll talk about
communication theory a little bit more
explicitly and talk about how agents
employ multiple communication channels
when they're communicating.
And this is obvious when you think of
people communicating, they not only talk
to each other, they look at the same
things, they point to things, et cetera.
So this is what I mean by multiple
communication channels.
Then in September, we'll leverage that
discussion to talk about how spacetime
actually emerges from communication.
And this is one of the most important
aspects, I think, of quantum information
theory.
It provides us with a way of viewing
spacetime as an emergent phenomenon, that
communication is what is fundamental in
some ontological sense, and the box in
which it happens, spacetime is not.
So the final session in October will talk
about applications to biology via the
free energy principle and future
directions both in physics and biology
and elsewhere.
So it's going to be an interesting ride.
I'm keeping formalism to a minimum
because we're directing this toward the
broad array of people who are interested
in active inference and who are involved
with the Active Inference Institute.
And I would ask you to hold questions
because we have a lot to get through in
an hour for the interactive discussion
and for the discussion forum.
So I hope I explain things well enough
that all of the concepts will be
understandable.
If not, Wikipedia is actually a wonderful
resource in this area for just
definitions of terms.
So if there's anything that just a term
that is a trip up, try Wikipedia.
It's probably a very good source for what
these terms mean.
So let's start our story, as I said,
begins in the 19th century.
And in the mid 19th century, lots of
physicists were devoting their efforts to
figuring out how to make better steam
engines.
And one question that arises when you're
trying to design a steam engine is what
happens physically when you add heat to a
system at constant temperature?
So if you're building a steam engine, you'
've got a boiler, because you need to
make steam.
And as you turn up the heat to your
boiler, you get more steam, but the
temperature doesn't change.
So this is a mystery.
What is the heat actually adding to the
boiler that is not increasing the
temperature?
And Clausius responded to this question
in a way that's sort of typical for a
physicist or a mathematician.
Since he didn't know what the answer was,
he just invented a new name for whatever
it was and gave it a formal definition.
So he called it entropy, which is a made
up word that, if it was translated from
the Greek, would roughly mean
transformation content in trophy.
And he represented it by a simple
equation that the change in this new
concept entropy, which is always called S,
, is just equal to the change in heat Q
at constant temperature t.
So obviously, this equation just
reformulates the question in declarative
form, saying whatever this stuff is, its
changes in this stuff are just changes in
heat at constant temperature.
Well, heat is energy.
And this wasn't completely recognized in
the mid 19th century, but the way you'll
see this equation in a current textbook
is DS is the change in energy at constant
temperature.
So even more commonly, you would see it
written as the change in energy is equal
to the temperature times the change in
entropy.
It's the most common sort of textbook way
of seeing this.
But the question, of course, is, what is
this quantity?
What is this entropy?
What does this concept mean?
And about 15 years after Klausius
proposed it, Boltzman had the key insight,
, which is that entropy is a measurement
of our uncertainty about the state the
system is in.
And in particular, he again, of course,
went to formalism and said, the entropy S
is equal to some constant times the
number of states that the system can be
in that look the same to us.
And since that number of states is
enormous, the way to make that manageable
is to take the log of the number of
states.
The natural log is ln.
And this constant k is called Baltimore's
constant.
And Baltimore was able to do this because
he subscribed to a radical, very
unpopular theory that material things,
including gases like air, were made of
atoms and heat made the atoms move around.
.
And as you increase the amount of heat,
the atoms can move in many different ways.
.
So the number of states that they can be
in that look the same to us increases.
And that's what entropy is.
It's this increase in the number of
states that the system can be in that all
look the same to us with the measurements
that we can make.
And since they look the same to us, we're
uncertain about exactly what state they'
're in.
So entropy is a measure of uncertainty.
This was really the beginning of modern
physics.
Because what it says now is that
decreasing uncertainty requires energy.
It links a measurement of uncertainty to
a measurement of energy.
And if you think about the uncertainty
principle in quantum theory, the core
idea of the uncertainty principle is you
can't measure a system without disturbing
it.
So to actually act on a system requires
energy.
And that's what you have to do to get
information.
So here's Boltzman, basically, inventing
quantum theory.
So we're going to fast forward by another
15 years, to 1900.
And in 1900, Planck solved this problem
called the black body radiation problem,
which was basically how much heat does
your hot boiler give off into the air?
And all of the measurements of the heat
that hot boilers gave off to the air ran
into problems in classical physics and
caused contradictions and quantities that
went to infinity.
And all of that was bad.
So many people were trying to solve this
problem, and Planck solved it by making a
simple postulate.
He said the energy of the radiation is
proportional to its frequency.
So its color in the case of light.
And if you go higher frequency, you end
up in ultraviolet and X rays and gamma
rays.
If you go to lower frequency, you go into
microwaves and radio and all of that.
So this is a nice way of talking about
radiation.
And it turned out that this solved the
problem.
I mean, just assuming this simple
proportionality relationship produced
spectra for black body radiation that
worked, that matched what you saw
experimentally.
Well, this means something very important.
.
It means because this number h, the
proportionality constant called plaque's
constant, is a number.
It's Finite.
It means that energy comes in discrete
units of H.
You can have one H or two H or 10 million
H, but you can't have half an H of energy.
.
So it's quantized.
And this is widely recognized as the
birth of quantum theory.
But of course, we should have known this
already.
If we just thought a little bit.
Right.
We Know that changes of energy are
proportional to changes in entropy by
temperature.
And we know that entropy is a measure of
the number of states, and numbers of
states are just numbers.
You can have one state, two states, three
states, 10 million states, 100 billion
states, but they're all just a number,
one up.
And it's not infinite.
There's not an infinite number of states
unless you have an infinite amount of
energy, which you don't have.
So we knew already that entropy could
only take discrete values.
And since energy and entropy are
basically the same thing, we knew already
that energy could only take discrete
values.
So we could have realized in 1900 that
energy is quantized because the number of
states is quantized.
So it shouldn't have really been a
mystery why energy was quantized, but it
was a mystery, and it stayed a mystery,
and it said, still a mystery.
People still debate the meaning of
quantum theory, but another thing we
could have known in 1900 was something
very important, and it's that this
quantum of action, planck's constant,
which has units of action, which is
energy times time, is intimately related
to Boltzman's constant.
And Boltzman's constant has units of
energy over temperature.
But this wasn't actually understood until
the 1950s.
No one really figured that this out.
There was this relation until the 1950s.
And when it was figured out, it was
figured out by a guy named Jean Carlo
Wick.
And he introduced this notion of the Wick
rotation by realizing that if you have an
equation in classical physics, and in it,
there's the term one over KT.
You can always replace that one over KT
with this other expression.
It over h bar.
H bar is just h divided by two pi, and
you'll get an equation that's valid in
quantum theory.
And this is typically described in
textbooks as a trick.
And whenever something in physics is
described as a trick, what that really
means is it's something we don't
understand.
And lots of papers have been written
about the meaning of the WIC rotation.
But to start to understand the WIC
rotation, I want to look at this equation
a little bit.
One over KT is one over in energy, and it
over h bar is one over in energy.
Since h bar is units of energy times time,
, we have time in this equation, and then
we have this factor, I, which is
typically thought of as just an imaginary
number.
So it's the square root of minus one.
And what's this I doing in this
equation?
And in fact, you see factors of it over h
bar.
If you're familiar with quantum theory
everywhere in quantum theory.
So what's the meaning of this imaginary
number?
And if you just think of it or of I as
this arbitrary imaginary number that
somehow renders the equation mysterious,
then the whole of quantum theory is
mysterious, but the Wick rotation is very
mysterious.
But what I is actually is an operator.
And if you think of the real numbers as
an axis, which is always drawn
horizontally.
So here it is.
Here's zero, and the axis is pointing
that way.
I'm sorry, I can't get the camera really
far enough away to see my arm here.
So what is I?
I is actually an operator that rotates
the whole real axis by 90 degrees.
So if you see a plot of complex numbers,
then the real numbers go this way, and
the, quote, imaginary numbers go that way.
.
So what multiplying by I has done is
rotate by 90 degrees.
And of course, if you do I squared, you
rotate twice by 90 degrees by arm would
do this, but you end up pointing that way,
, and those are the negative numbers.
So I is an operator that rotates
something by 90 degrees, and if you
rotate four times by 90 degrees, you're
back to the identity.
So I to the fourth is one.
So this tells us something very
interesting, which is that what the WIC
rotation is really talking about is a
rotation.
It's a geometrical equation.
And in July, we'll come back to this and
really probe what this Wick rotation
means physically.
But as I said, this wasn't understood to
the 1950s, and by the 1950s, a lot had
happened.
So quantum theory had been developed.
Bohren Einstein had had their debate.
Particle accelerators had been built.
The atomic bomb had been built.
Nuclear physics was well in its way, so
an enormous amount of practical physics
had been done.
Quantum theory was highly developed.
People were starting to think about
quantum field theory before they made
this simple realization that's formulated
in the Wick rotation.
So this is a harboring of things to come.
.
But before we continue in physics, we
need to backtrack in time a little bit
and look at what the mathematicians were
doing.
So across the hall in the math department,
, one year after the Solve conference in
1929, kurt Godel proved his famous first
incompleteness theorem.
And the theorem states that no formal
system that contains arithmetic can be
both consistent and complete.
And that means that either there are true
statements that aren't provable in the
formal system, or there are false
statements that are provable, or, of
course, both.
And Godel's proof is actually extremely
simple.
Almost all of the work in the proof is
setting up all of the notation and
procedures and so forth to formulate
within arithmetic the sentence, this
sentence is not provable.
And once you have that sentence
formulated within arithmetic, then the
conclusion of the proof is obvious.
If you can prove the sentence, this
sentence is not provable, then you've
proved something that's false.
And if you can't prove it, then there are
sentences that you can't prove in
arithmetic.
So this was incredibly bad news for
mathematicians who thought that finite
discrete operations, which is what proofs
are and also what computations are, can
exhaustively enumerate the facts and this
was the assumption behind Wittgenstein's
claim that the world is all that is the
case, the world is a collection of facts.
.
And optimistically, he thought that first
order logic would allow us to enumerate
all those facts and we'd be done dreams
of a final theory again.
So Godel's Theorem means that no system
with finite capabilities, no system that
can just do finite discrete operations,
can fully describe its environment.
It will always be in an environment where
there are true things that aren't
provable or false things that are
provable.
But I think more relative to a discussion
of agents is that it means that no agent
can describe itself.
Any agent's theory of itself will either
contain true statements that it can't
derive or false statements, or it will
either miss true statements that it can't
derive or wind up deriving things that
are false about itself.
Of course, we see this in psychology all
the time.
So an immediate consequence of Godel's
Theorem was an intense investigation of
what computation actually is, what it
meant to talk about finite discrete
operations.
And two leaders of this were, of course,
Church and Turing.
And here's a picture of a Turing machine,
which is just a little device with a
couple of tapes and a tape reader and a
simple logic unit that either writes a
one or a zero if it sees a one or a zero.
.
And they defined a computation as a
process that can be implemented in finite
time by such a machine or by Church's
lambda calculus or by any of the now
hundreds of other methods that are
provably equivalent to a Turing machine.
So what does this mean?
It means that computation is a physical
process that can be mechanized and it
turns out, mechanized in any one of a
huge array of ways.
It means that many different
implementations of any computation are
possible.
So I can do it on a Turing machine, I can
do it on my laptop, I can do it on my
head, et cetera.
The most important things it means is
that there are questions with no
computable answer.
This is the Revenge of Godel's theorem.
And two of the most famous questions of
this kind are given some arbitrary
program.
Will it halt?
Will it get to an answer in finite time?
And the answer to that question is this
is undecidable.
No procedure can figure this out.
And the other undecidable question is,
given some arbitrary program, what
function does it compute?
And you'd think that would be simple,
that you can read a program and figure
out what function it computes.
But it turns out that is undecidable.
That cannot be done by any finite process.
.
So this was another body blow to the goal
of understanding everything with finite
discrete processes.
But it also set the stage for something
new.
It set the stage for thinking about an
agent who interacts with a computational
process by giving it an input and then
looking at its output sometime later.
And this, of course, will look familiar
because I've included the blue ellipse,
which is the boundary, which these days
we call a user interface.
And the user interface just allows some
finite action on the system and then the
ability to observe some finite response
by the system.
So we can now ask what can Alice
determine by acting in some finite way
and then making some finite number of
observations I.
E.
Receiving some finite number of outputs
from the system that she's acting on.
And the first 20 years of this produced a
large number of answers, all of them
negative.
So to go back to Turing, he proved that
Alice can't tell what's implementing the
function that she sees being implemented.
.
She can't tell whether a given input will
lead to an output.
That's the halting problem.
Shannon showed that Alice can't tell what
the inputs mean to the system.
His whole theory of communication is
completely independent of semantics.
And his theory of communication actually
accurately describes what Alice can
observe.
Rice is the one who proved that you can't
determine what program is generating the
outputs.
And then Moore proved a very similar
result in a completely different formal
setting of general cybernetics that you
can't tell what process is generating the
outputs by finite observation.
But what Alice can do is build a
predictive model of what generates the
output she sees in response to her inputs
and test it by designing new inputs.
And this is, of course, as Karl Popper
told us, the process that we call science.
.
So Alice can do science even though she
can't answer any of these fundamental
questions.
Now, this, of course, has a huge
technological consequence since this
theory of computation tells us that
processes are effectively virtual.
We don't know what they are and we can't
determine what they are except in theory.
.
By making a theory technologically, it
means we're free to use virtualization
everywhere because we have to deal with
it anyway.
And this allows us to build multilevel
architectures.
It means that we can architect computers
where no layer of the computation has any
idea what's going on below or above it
and doesn't need to.
And that's what makes practical
programming possible.
So from these no go theorems that tell
you what you can't do, you actually get
an enormous boost into it and use to
probe the world and develop theories and
on and on and on.
So in a sense, Godel birthed not only
computer science, but practical computing
by showing us that virtualization is just
the way the world works.
So now let's go back to physics where
these ideas were replicated, basically
reintroduced, reinvented by Feynman in
developing his path integral formulation
of quantum theory.
And basically what Feyman realized was
that in any physical process, the
observer Alice prepares some state that
she's interested in.
She prepares some input to an experiment.
.
Then she lets something happen, and then
she sees what the result of the
experiment is.
And the canonical experiment in physics
is scattering.
You fire two protons at each other, and
they intersect someplace, and stuff comes
out, and you measure the stuff that comes
out.
And what you can measure is momentum and
spin energy, things like that position.
So these processes conserve the total
values of the things you can measure.
So in particular, they preserve momentum
and angular momentum, and they preserve
other things that are harder to measure
and are only approximately conserved
anyway, like Lepton number.
But Feynman's contribution to this way of
thinking about experiments was to say,
look, if you want to understand the
output, you have to sum over all of the
possible processes that could have
produced the output from the input, no
matter how improbable they are.
So the famous idea from Feynman diagrams
is if you have an electron that's
scattering off an atom, you measure the
initial state of the electron that you've
generated with an accelerator or
something, and you measure the final
state, which involves momentum and spin
and so forth.
And for all you knew, partway through the
process, the electron disappeared, and an
entire universe appeared and then
annihilated with a copy of an entire anti
universe, and the electron came back out.
.
And you have to include processes like
that if you really want to understand and
correctly predict the outcomes of your
measurements.
And Murray Gelman lifted the bumper
sticker slogan from Th White and the once
and Future King everything not explicitly
forbidden is mandatory.
That sums up Feynman's idea.
And this is called the totalitarian
principle, since it's what's written in
Th White's book on the kingdom of the
ants, for which everything not explicitly
forbidden is mandatory.
So let's think about a real example that'
's a bit actually, it's the same as
scattering.
The ultimate scattering experiment in
physics is a black hole.
Stuff goes into the horizon, stars, whole
galaxies, whatever.
Something happens, and stuff comes out.
And what comes out is Hawking radiation,
and information is conserved if the
information in the Hawking radiation is
actually the same as the information in
the stuff that went in.
And conservation is not qualitative.
It's quantitative.
It's only the quantity of information
that's supposed to be preserved.
And you can ask, how much is the
information that's being emitted by a
black hole that's emitting Hawking
radiation?
And Beckenstein was the one who figured
this out, using an incredibly simple
argument.
But I'll just give the answer here.
The answer is that the total entropy of
the black hole is its area divided by
four, and the area in this equation has
to be computed in Planck units, which are
units where Planck's constant and the
speed of light and boltzman's constant
and other interesting things are all set
equal to one.
So one Planck area is the Planck length
squared, which turns out to be about ten
to the minus squared.
So this is that black holes are the most
entropic entities we know of.
So a black hole about this big with a
radius of about a meter has an entropy of
about ten to the 70th, which is, of
course, an astonishingly big number, and
a black hole with the area of the sun.
So a moderate sized cosmological black
hole, a real thing that we can observe
with a gravity wave telescope or
something, has an entropy of about ten to
the 79th.
And really big black holes, which are
bigger than the entire solar system, have
entropies into the ten to the something.
So these are enormously entropic entities.
.
But Beckenstein didn't just tell us that.
He told us something about the structure
of the interface, the horizon of a black
hole.
And this is what he told us.
You can compute entropy in bits just by
using logs, base two instead of logs
based e, natural logs.
And that's just multiplying the natural
log by about 1.4.
So we can write the entropy of black hole,
, of black hole in units of bits, and it'
's about a over six.
So what does this mean to say that we can
think of the entropy in terms of bits?
What it says is that we can think of the
interface in terms of a bit array, and we
can think of all of these bits as encoded
on this interface at a density of one bit
every roughly six plank lengths squared,
six plank areas.
So this is an incredibly dense encoding
in a black hole.
And it's an interesting idea about black
holes.
But what gets really interesting is what
happens when you generalize it.
And of course, physicists are prone to
generalization, and that's what happened
next.
Gerard to Hooft, almost immediately
thereafter, on the basis of Beckenstein's
work, formulated the Holographic
principle.
And what the Holographic principle says
is we can think of any system as
approximately a black hole.
And the only approximation is the
encoding density.
The boundary of any system encodes the
information that we can get about the
system at some density.
And the density is less than the density
for a black hole because we're not black
holes.
And this rules out a lot by limiting the
amount of information that you can
extract from a system to the amount of
information that you can actually write
on its boundary.
And one of the things that it rules out
is knowing the geometry on the inside of
the system.
And to Hoof put it this way, which I
think is a brilliant thought experiment,
he says, look, the metric inside this
system can be so curved, effectively the
space time inside the system can be so
curved that you could stick an entire
universe inside.
And we never know because it wouldn't
change the amount of entropy number of
bits that are encoded on the boundary.
So the inside geometry can be anything.
And you can't find out by.
Looking at the outside of the system.
Now, the Holographic principle almost
follows from classical physics.
There's Euler's theorem, which tells you
about one over R squared forces, and you
can think of the force as penetrating the
boundary at some density.
And the difference between Euler's
theorem and the Holographic principle is
just that the density in classical
physics can go to infinity.
And in the Holographic principle, it can
only go to this maximal density that's
achieved by a black hole.
Why?
Because if you try to get any higher,
more information, the information gets
sucked into the black hole, and you can't
get it out.
So the Holographic principle becomes a
guiding principle for thinking about any
physical system and what it means to
extract information from a physical
system.
And in fact, we'll talk about this next
time.
You can say exactly what the information
encoded on the boundary of any system is.
.
And what I'll go through next time is
seeing that the information that's
encoded on the boundary is a
specification of the energy that's being
exchanged by the interaction, which, of
course, is linear in the number of bits.
It's just counting the number of bits.
Okay?
So with the Holographic principle, we now
have a complete new science about systems
that are exchanging finite discrete
information across a boundary by encoding
that information on the boundary and then
reading the information off the boundary.
.
So here's a new way of thinking about
physical interaction.
Alice writes a message on her boundary
with Bob, and Bob reads the message off
the boundary and then writes his own new
message, which Alice then reads.
And of course, that's what's happening
right now.
I'm writing information by speaking on an
interface, which is effectively the
Internet.
And you're reading that information off
the Internet by listening to it.
And when we get time for questions, you'
'll be writing information on the
Internet, which I'll be reading.
Now, the key thing about this new science
is that it's topological.
It's about connectivity across some
communication channel, which we represent
as a boundary.
It's not geometric, so it doesn't assume
anything about spacetime.
So it allows us to build a model of space
in particular as an emergent phenomenon.
And it allows us to see time as not some
absolute external abstraction, but
something that the communicating agents
measure for themselves.
And so they each act in their own time.
And we get a very natural measure of time
in terms of how many bits I see coming
across my boundary.
And again, we'll talk about that in the
next couple of sessions and then talk
about it more thoroughly in September
when we talk about emergent spacetime.
So quantum information theory looks very
different from the physics that came
before, not because it's adopted a new
formalism, the tools of quantum theory.
It's because it's entirely changed the
thinking about what physics is and what
it's about and replace this idea of
forces and balls banging into each other
and all of that with the idea of
communication between agents.
And of course that's familiar from an
active inference perspective.
So we can now back up a little bit to see
what they were doing in classical physics
during this period.
Well, let me go on a little bit.
Sorry.
This is just a slide quoting Wheeler, who
of course is the most radical in terms of
impitheist, in terms of formulating these
ideas.
But here's his characterization of this
new physics.
It's not reductive.
All of the reasoning is circular.
You don't have smaller things and then
yet smaller things, and then yet smaller
things forever.
There are no laws.
So what you see on the interface is a
message.
It's not something that's governed by
laws since the beginning of the universe.
.
There's no continuum.
So there's nothing described by real
numbers.
It's all described by integers.
Everything's done in finite dimensional
spaces.
And finally, and most importantly, there'
's no spacetime box in which things
happen.
So think of how radical this is means.
There's no big bang, there's no big rip,
there's no bouncing universe.
All of those ideas are out the window
because they're classical and they're
about spacetime.
And what the new physics wants to do is
derive spacetime out of basically users
experiences.
So the agents here are all observer
participants in Wheeler's language.
But what that just means is agents that
want to communicate and it's their
communication that gives rise to physics.
.
So now we'll go back to classical physics
and what was happening, or one thing that
was happening in classical physics at
that time was a lot of thinking about
stochastic causal networks.
And Pearl realized that if you have any
stochastic causal network that's
unidirectional, then around any node, you
can draw what he called a Markov blanket.
.
And a Markov blanket is just the set of
nodes in the network that absorb all
outside causation and then transmit that
causation into whatever node you're
interested in and then absorb all
causation coming from the node you're
interested in and transmit it to the rest
of the world.
And so we can redraw that in Part B here,
and it should look very familiar.
A Markov blanket is just a classical
physics way of talking about a
Holographic screen.
And the number of nodes in the Markov
blanket, or in particular the number of
degrees of freedom times the number of
nodes, is just the number of bits that
flow across that Markov blanket.
So it's the entropy of the effective
Holographic screen.
All these ideas were reinvented more or
less independently within classical
physics.
And it was from this classical physics
background that Karl Freston came up with
the idea that a Markov blanket defines a
persistence, at least from an active
inference institute point of view
everyone is familiar with, because it's
the foundation of the idea of active
inference.
Any system that persists through time
does so by making sure that it doesn't
dissolve into its environment.
Well, what does that mean?
It means it persists through time by
maintaining the integrity of its Markov
blanket or the integrity of its boundary.
.
So this of course is just a tautology,
but it's a very interesting and very
productive tautology because it says that
any system is using the information it
gets on its boundary from its environment
to build a model of how its environment
behaves.
And then it uses that model to act back
on its environment to test and refine its
model.
And again, as Popper told us, this is
just what science is.
So what the free energy principle really
tells us is that all systems are agents
that are doing science all the time.
So physics is effectively not just the
study of communication, but it's the
study of agents doing science with each
other, pairs of agents who are trying to
figure each other out by their
communicative exchanges.
So that's the history of how we got from
1930s sorry, 1850s thermodynamics to the
free energy principle and how the free
energy principle connects to these very
deep and extremely radical, especially
within context ideas in quantum theory
and quantum cosmology and computer
science.
All of which tell us that the world we
see is a projection that's being written
on our boundaries by a process that we
have no access to except the procedure of
active inference or the procedure of
science, which is to formulate predictive
models and test them by doing things in
the world and seeing how the world
responds.
So that's it for this session.
The first discussion session which Andrew
is going to lead will be the 3 June at
this same time, I E 05:00 European time.
And then my session number two will be in
mid June.
And if you look at the course website,
there's this subsidiary website for
interactive Q and A.
And I invite everyone to post questions
and discuss them and hope that we'll have
an interesting exchange and that everyone
will come to sort of an understanding of
what was talked about today through
discussion.
And we'll be interested in being back in
June to see how to formulate this in
quantum theory.
So thank you very much and thank you
again, Daniel, for organizing this and
hosting it and putting together all the
technical things necessary to pull this
off.
I could never do that on my own.
Daniel: Thank you.
We're really excited here.
Any closing thoughts?
Or andrew, I'd love to hear your
reflection just briefly.
How would you have told that history or
how does that history reflect on the
areas that you're familiar with?
Ander: Well, I don't think I have much to
add.
I've been mainly interested in the weak
rotation part.
I'm excited to hear more about that,
Chris.
But no, I found this to be a very nice
summary.
I'm less familiar with the staff on
computation, formal computation, despite
being a mathematician by training, it was
a little more familiar with all the
physics stuff, but yeah, I thought it was
great.
Chris: Thank you.
All right.
Daniel: Thank you.
I will close it.
So in about two weeks, we'll have the
first discussion.
Everyone's welcome to join.
I will share with Honor and Chris the
questions, and we can develop that.
And we'll have that on the course, front
end before the coming discussion.
So thanks again, fellows.
See you next time.
Chris: Bye.